[Applause]
we went to Google because we needed a
robust platform that would allow us to
adjust any kind of data at volume
ingesting data is one thing but making
sense of it is another ones that we
transition to Chronicle we start
receiving a large that we never seen
before
we have advanced capabilities around
threat intelligence that are highly
integrated into the chronicle platform
we like the orchestration capabilities
to enrich the data provide additional
context to it during Chronicle theme
allows us to not have to compromise on
the amount of data and the different log
sources we bring same and this is
something we were never able to do
before so it is amazing
anybody in the same role that I am is
going to see the benefit right away
[Applause]
the workbooks and the playbooks we can
create are tremendous value and
automation for me in the future it is
automation anything that Google is the
right partner to accomplish this vision
foreign